today we're gonna play for you my first
of two interviews that I did it
at Netroots nation in New Orleans
Louisiana where I was last week this one
is with JD Schulten who's running
against Steve King the incumbent
Republican you'll notice that at one
point during the interview a second-line
band starts playing and that was not
something that we knew was going to
happen but we did the best to power
through my interview from Netroots with
JD Schulten I'm here with JD Schulten
who's running in Iowa's fourth District
against Republican incumbent Steve King
a pill battle for sure uphill battle but
what we're seeing is it's a lot of new
things that we haven't seen in years and
this race is going to come down to the
wire a lot of these races we're seeing
in your race we're seeing with Ted Cruz
and Texas and other races races where
the fundraising numbers are actually
pretty pretty solid for the Challenger
but in the end it's money it's
incumbency it's a lot of different
things let's talk about the money part
first I mean what's your approach when
it comes to the fundraising well I like
to it's funny you mentioned that race
because we find ourselves very similar
when you have such a an opponent who's
well known like that there's a lot of
people who want to get involved for
three consecutive quarters we've raised
money in all 39 counties in our district
and in all 50 states we do traditional
meet and greets to call time but we also
do a lot of digital and we get connected
with folks all across the nation and
we've been able to help raise him this
entire election cycle and in the last
nine months by a two-to-one margin
that's that's stunning I mean we know
that I think it's something like 85
percent of races end up being won by the
candidate that raises more money of
course there is the power of incumbency
as well but that's the I think one of
the advantages and tell me if I'm wrong
to being a challenge
against a very well-known candidate is
that the entire country maybe is more
aware of the race and has an incentive
to try to help out and get that
incumbent out if it's not a popular
person absolutely I mean nobody should
really know who the 4th congressional
district representative is yet most of
America does and and that's the thing
when he makes his off-color comments
which are more and more frequent I have
friends who aren't political who aren't
from Iowa and they they text me or call
me and say hey is this you and I like to
say that it doesn't represent us or he
doesn't represent us but representative
is his job title and I'm trying to
change that
what are your sort of big issues in the
campaign and for people who aren't
familiar with this this particular
district is very rural so that's it's
unique I mean there's there's role rural
parts of Iowa and less rural parts what
are the primary issues that that you're
focusing on and that voters are telling
you are important to them right
well it's interesting thing because
right now we're doing a lot of farm
forums or in round tables and as much as
we're talking about tariffs or low
commodity prices or trying to break into
more markets we talked about health care
and farmers are working that second or
third job or their spouses work in that
second to third job in town for
generations that hasn't been the case
just to pay for health care and I mean I
have no problem going into some of the
most rural parts of the district talking
about Medicare for all and people being
on board what the there's posit is the
positive response is it because the farm
community in particular has a deficit
when it comes to health care is it
because the idea of Medicare for all
specifically is becoming more popular do
you think even in rural areas I think
just the need is so desperate that
people are willing to do whatever it
takes every time I stop for gas I travel
a lot in
within the district and every time I
stop for gas most of the gas stations
have a donation box and it's usually
someone we've just gotten an accident or
got cancer or some illness and my goal
is to get rid of that I mean we live in
the wealthiest country in the world that
it's just we need to get to have a
system that doesn't rely on donations to
pay for health care and then people
relate to that and and I think wherever
you are on the spectrum
people feel that there's a need now I
mean we have decades that the private
industries could have done something and
this is where we're at and the need is
now and the need is it's boiling up
amongst most folks with a
medicare-for-all type proposal would you
favor something at the federal level
that would be paid for maybe through
like an income tax the way Bernie
Sanders has proposed there's other ideas
that would be at the state level there's
differences between universal coverage
and an actual government-funded system
what's your approach
honestly I'm open the meat is so I feel
so desperate that whatever we can do to
get there let's do it and I'm flexible
I don't believe that one way is the only
way and so what I like to tell folks
does I get I asked up quite a bit how
are we gonna pay for it well America is
four percent of the world's population
yet we're 41 percent of the world's
wealth somewhere in there is the answer
and would you so I mean let's let's talk
a little more specifically if the idea
was something at the federal level seems
more the more the ideas are at the
federal level than state right would you
reallocate money that is already a
government revenue or would you do an
additional income tax the way Bernie has
proposed honestly I haven't really
weighed exactly how we would go about it
but but I'd be open to either
I mean seems like the tax could be a
hard sell in some rural places right
like right but but also you tell them
like hey you're paying for it it's like
instead of paying for health insurance
if you're paying for for it to attacks
and and I think they get when when you
get something in return it's not as much
of the taxes as what they made new taxes
at that that mindset so I think they'd
be open to it and I mean we've talked
about that in several of these world
meeting Greeson and so I think people
are open to it
tariffs tariffs right now are hitting
farmers really hard they're hitting
farmers in the Midwest really really
hard and yet for the most part they're
sticking with Trump and that concerns me
a lot because at this point we would
hope that there would be some
repercussions and some consequences if
it felt like we were going to see those
I'd be more confident about the midterms
you're on the ground specifically in the
fourth District of Iowa how are the
farmers dealing with the Trump tariffs
well here's the thing as
even before the tariffs farmers have
been anxious and there is if we just
talk about the tariffs that that doesn't
really get to the root of the problem
and in that the bailout I like to say
that it's like you got punched in the
face and then they gave you an ice pack
like just don't punch me in the face
and it's not as big an issue but I mean
I'm talking to the port producers and
the dairy farmers they're feeling hit
right now where you see the row crops
the soybean farmers and the corn growers
like they can hold off a little bit to
the harvest but they're I mean they're
so anxious and so we've had four
consecutive years the low commodity
prices soybeans are down I mean corn is
down there three bucks a bushel and you
need needed about 350 to break even and
so farmers are struggling to get the
loans that they need and so they're it's
a lot it goes a lot deeper than just a
terrace but I all I see is that farmers
are anxious and they're willing to
listen where they haven't been able to
listen
what do you feel like they're holding
Trump accountable I I think there would
be when it comes back up there a little
bit patient but when it comes the people
like representative King he's not on the
farm bill committee the conference
committee and like if I wasn't an issue
I darn sure that I'd be fighting to get
on that community shoot the nail and and
fighting for the people in my district
and he's not doing that and that's what
they feed more than they actually
probably related to Trump Steve King is
I don't know if in cahoots is the right
word but he's associated with Trump in a
lot of ways is that helping him in that
district or is that at this point of
liability this it's actually two
completely different things I do it I'm
not the type of I don't limp I lump them
together I know a lot of folks do
because you think there's a man but I
could name probably twenty people have
to top of my head who are Trump
supporters who are a board of that and
so the feeling of fatigue is there with
King where Trump is still new they're
still trying to play it out a little bit
so Steve King and Donald Trump by many
voters seen as sort of affiliated on the
same page when it comes to a lot of
different issues in the district is that
the perception is the perception that a
vote for King is a vote for Trump and
support of Trump means you support Steve
King see I see it differently in the
districts I could name twenty people at
the top of my head who support us but
also still support Trump and so the
thing with King is there's a fatigue
that's part of this because for 16 years
he's been saying controversial things
he's been saying things that have put a
blemish on on the 4th district and and
it's just one of those things where as
an outsider you think would go hand in
hand but what we're seeing on the ground
level is they're two completely
different things
the rural districts often are sort of
misunderstood by people on the coasts
and big cities and there's this sort of
talking point that because the coastal
elites so-called just didn't get sort of
what's happening in middle America that
that helped Donald Trump win I don't
know that I even agree with that
narrative but let's sort of like think
about it a little bit is there something
about rural America that people who have
not visited those parts of the country
just don't get about the day-to-day
lives of people that infant impacts
their politics yeah I have a tough time
answering that question because I mean I
was born and raised there like I get it
I get what why Trump was successful
there I I understand like my district I
and the reason why they continue to vote
I don't necessarily agree with it but
but it's one of those things where in a
district like ours retail politics and
old-school style of politics that's what
works like as much as like the wave of
digital and all this stuff it's it's
door-knocking it's getting out there and
in Iowa we're spoiled when you want
let's say you want Joe Biden to your
birthday party barbecue you can get him
on a presidential year and so you really
got to get out there you can't just sit
at home raise fund raise and
commercials that's not going to win you
a darn thing it's getting out there and
showing how prove how hard you're gonna
work
prove that you're trustworthy and prove
that you're gonna fight for the people
of the district and you're gonna earn
votes regardless of their voter history
so in Boston where we're in a very
different political situation than in
any part of Iowa a big conversation
right now is how split is the left
democratic socialism versus social
democracy fighting centrist Democrats
versus trying to knock out Republicans
and how do you spread resources are
those even conversations in a place like
the fourth District you know when we
launched our campaign a year ago there
was that that's what that Bernie Hillary
split but I think one of the best things
that our campaign and the most success
that our campaign has is that we're an
open tent and and that we've been able
to bring both sides together and I mean
part of it is when you go up against
King I think people just want to beat
him and they're willing to accept things
but but I want a primary and I was
further left and the other two and so I
don't think that necessarily won me the
primary but being younger and just
having those kind of views kind of
people associate me with the left a
little bit more so it's I'm fighting to
be a Democrat in Iowa and you just look
across the Midwest and it's hard to come
by and so when you go to these national
events it's that that split and I don't
see it just because I'm fighting to be a
Democrat are there issues you have to be
more careful of as a Democrat in a red
state running against somebody who's
been there for a while whether it's
because on average the population is
more religious than in some other parts
of the country the issue of abortion
does gay rights even come up at this
point or is it seen sort of like as a
settled issue because of the Supreme
Court decision
I feel it's settled in Iowa we were the
third state accepted which was ahead of
its time and the first Midwest
I'm not running or to lose
I'm not running to hide I'm running on
Who I am and what I believe in and I
think that resonates more than kind of
being wishy-washy about an issue it's a
very religious district I'm Catholic
myself but you get caught in these
debates and it's not as black white as
what people think when you talk about
abortions and and my goal is to reduce
the number of abortions and that
something both sides can agree upon and
so I really don't view it as I got a
watch what I'm saying or anything like
that I just run on Who I am when it
comes to legislation what would be the
first three things you work on if you
want health care absolutely I would a
campaign finance reform that's the one
thing I can agree with anybody my
neighbor has a truck the size of Texas
as he caucus for Trump and as probably
five ar-15s we don't agree on too many
things but the one thing we can always
agree upon is getting money out of
politics and so so those are the two the
third thing some of the help our farmers
years and years of consolidation the
fresh and the stress that our that these
farmers have to go a year and you're out
I mean the terrorists couldn't come at a
worse time
an absolute worse time
and we're feeling it in our districts
well I think the band is playing us off
I'm mistaking with JD Scholten who's
running against the incumbent Republican
Steve King in Iowa's fourth District
great to meet you they saw mine